as we've already seen the 5th century
bce
starts off with athens and sparta and
various greek city-states fighting on
the same side against
against the persian invaders but as we
saw in the last video as soon as the
person as soon as the persians are dealt
with tensions start to rise between
athens and sparta and their various
allies sparta gets worried that the
athenian navy is looking maybe a little
bit too strong they were decisively
important in the second persian invasion
and they they build this delian league
which whose purpose is to go on the
offensive against the persians but more
and more so it was starting to look like
an athenian empire and a lot of this you
can imagine it's like a game of risk the
more you take over the more resources
you have the more that you can build
more ships and have more soldiers so
that you can take on even more so as
sparta and athens are starting to become
more and more uh more and more rivals
sparta is getting insecure about athens
influence and their resources and their
military power
and we even saw it in the last video you
have an earthquake in sparta potentially
right around the same time that sparta
was planning an invasion of athens
leaving the spartans vulnerable there's
a hell out uprising these these spartan
slaves the athenians send hoplites to to
apparently help the spartans but the
spartans are suspicious of it and they
send them back and then it it culminates
with
the the skirmish you have between megara
and corinth which were historically to
spartan allies but athens decides to
take sides gets an alliance with megara
and that's that's one thing too many for
the spartans and so they declare war and
you have what's called the first
peloponnesian war but that's not the
peloponnesian war that's the first time
that you start having very open conflict
between the spartans and the athenians
and these conflicts last for on the
order of about 15 years and they're
ended with what's called the peace of 30
years but as we will see this piece of
30 years only lasts
only lasts about 15 years and the whole
time tensions continue to arise the
delian league or you could call it the
athenian power the athenian empire i
should say is getting more and more
powerful the athenian navy is getting
more and more powerful and once again
things culminate and now this is the
beginning of the actual peloponnesian
war the thing that people are referring
to when they talk about the
peloponnesian war in 431 bce
the king of asparta is is
is
convinced or is i guess you could say he
is um
he is influenced to
even though he himself was somewhat
skeptical of the idea he decides to
invade attica attica is something you'll
hear a lot about it is this region right
over here this little out jutting of
land that athens is on and this first
phase of the peloponnesian war is called
the arcademian war named for the king of
sparta who somewhat reluctant
reluctantly gets convicted gets
decides to invade attica and so
that stage one
archaedamian
arcademian
war and the arcademian war it's
it's essential ingredients are you have
sparta with its dominant army going and
having repeated attacks onto
attica and the athenians with their
dominant navy going and having raids
throughout the peloponnese and along the
aegean coast so here you have the
athenians
going let me do the athenians and the
spartans in two different colors
actually
so here you go let's do the spartans in
this red color
attacking attica with their army and now
let's have the athenians with this light
blue color
coming here and attacking various points
various points on the peloponnese and in
the aegean
further extending their influence
now that first phase ends and it goes on
for quite a bit it goes on for about 10
years ends with the peace of nisius or
niceas but as you'll see and that was
actually intended to be a 50-year piece
but you'll see it doesn't last long at
all
and the skirmishes continue and in 415
the athenians say hey we want to extend
our power remember it's like this game
of risk the more city-states you take
over the more citizens that you're able
to tax the more soldiers you will have
the more wealth you will have the more
ship-building capability you will have
so the athenians get this great idea to
sail all the way to syracuse and just to
be clear where syracuse is syracuse
right over here on the coast of sicily
and this is a long distance in this
ancient world today get this idea to
sail all the way to syracuse to try to
take it over for in and essentially to
extend their empire
so this right over here is in
415
this long voyage
to take over
syracuse and it is disastrous the fleet
that tries to go is able to be destroyed
and they get the the folks in syracuse
are able to get the assistance of the
spartans and so that greek fleet is
destroyed and this is often viewed as
the second phase of the peloponnesian
war and so this is the attack at
syracuse
attack
at syracuse the failed attempt of the
athenians at to get syracuse
to
get syracuse and this is a two-year
period of time because once again this
is no joke to send your navy and to try
to get at syracuse and then that takes
us into
the third phase
the third phase of the peloponnesian war
let me scroll this over a little bit
the third phase is often called the
ionian war
ionian
or ionian
ionian war ionia is this region that's
now on now in modern day off the coast
of modern day turkey you have many of
the city-states that were part of this
athenian empire they're starting to
revolt you can imagine that the spartans
are trying to help those revolts because
they're trying to get the athenians
wherever they are this is often also
called the desolatine or decoleen
desolatine
war
decellia
i'm probably not pronouncing well it's a
little village right over here at the
top of attica and it was a strategic
location that went over to the spartans
and that's where the decalion war gets
its name
but over the course of this third phase
the spartans get help from the persians
remember this was their enemy they had
unif the spartans and athenians had
unified against the persians but some
time has passed we're now 70 or 80 years
later and the spartans say hey we want
to win this thing decisively they get
the help of the persians and finally in
405 bce there's the decisive naval naval
battle
at ego
botami and i'm sorry to all of you
greeks out there that might be listening
i know my pronunciation is not perfect
or close to perfect but this is a
decisive victory right over here for the
spartans they are able to destroy the
athenian navy and that
causes that's the decisive victory and
then in 404 this is 405 and 404 the
athenians surrender and the famous
peloponnesian war is over the spartans
are victorious but it's not a great
victory because as you can imagine
you have towns that have been destroyed
large parts of of greece have been
weakened
and it leaves the the whole area open to
attack from others and as we will see in
the next century in the 4th century we
have philip of macedon or macadam
depending on how you want to pronounce
it who's able to use that vulnerable and
the macedonians are the macedonians they
are related to the greek people but he's
able to use that vulnerability that
happens over the course of the fifth
century to attack the city-states of
greece but he actually is able to unify
them